Alhamdulillah.
[Silence]
continuing in
the chapters regarding the virtues of
salah and the dangers of abandoning
salah or squandering the opportunity of
salah or incomplete Complete salah.
[Silence]
on the authority
He says, "I heard the messenger of
Allah.
Wasam say five prayers
that Allah has prescribed and obligated
upon his slaves.
Whoever fulfills and offers these five
prayers
and has not lost any of them out of
a lack of concern or a lack of
exaltation of these prayers. This person
has
a an allegiance and a promise, a solemn
oath from Allah
that he will enter him into paradise.
We'll take that again so that we can
remember. He says five prayers,
you know,
five prayers Allah has obligated upon
his slaves.
Whoever fulfills them and does not lose
any of them or fails to fulfill them
because of a lack of concern
and exaltation of their position.
This person has an oath and a promise
from Allah that he will admit him into
paradise.
He says, "And whoever does not fulfill
them, then this person has no
promise from Allah. If Allah wishes, he
will punish him. And if Allah wishes, he
will forgive him."
This narration was collected by Im Ahmed
and others.
He says
[Silence]
foreign.
canchech.
[Silence]
on the authority of Abi Rahu narrates as
well that he heard the messenger of
Allah
say indeed the first thing that the
Muslim servant slave of Allah will be
brought to judgment for on the day
of judgment is his obligated prayer.
And if he has brought it forth fulfilled
and complete,
then it will be accepted from him. And
if not, if it is incomplete,
Allah will command to look for
optional prayer that he may have made
and it will be used to patch his
obligatory prayers.
and likewise will be done with all of
the rest of his deeds.
Right? So meaning
in fasting
he will be judged for his obligatory
fasting. If there's any missing,
deficient, anything rewardless, anything
that Allah does not accept, this doesn't
just mean that he didn't do it. Because
some of the scholars use this as an
evidence that
even if a person misses prayer that this
is you know something that is a major
sin but is not so major that the
person is hopeless. this evidence. There
are other evidences much stronger than
this for that purpose. But the point is
is that
his fasting for instance it's deficient
or he did something to nullify it or he
did something that deems it un
unacceptable by Allah or unrewarded by
Allah
then it will be said look to his
optional acts of fasting
and it will be used to patch his
obligatory fasting
and likewise zak and likewise.
Omra and likewise all other avenues of
worship. So the person's
worship will be first judged based on
how well they fulfilled the obligatory
aspects of that worship. If there's a
deficiency
then the optional worship in that vein
and that avenue will be used to patch
it.
This narration has been collected by
Iben Maja. Now, sometimes it's difficult
to understand
at first glance some of these
narrations because when you look at
narrations that have this kind of start,
it's the first thing that a person
will be judged for on the day of
judgment.
in some narrations it is the first
thing people will be judged for is
murder. In some places the first thing a
person will be judged for is salah. In
some instances the first thing that a
person will be judged for. So how do we
harmonize these? This is relative.
So the first thing that a person
individually
as a slave of Allah and his worship will
be judged for is salah.
The first thing that Allah will address
with respects to grievances between the
servants is murder. you know spilling
of blood before monetary grievances
before grievances of property before
grievances of reputation etc. And so
these are relative things first but it
is relative to the context.
Another thing that is important to
remember here is that salah is so
important that the believer the Muslim
is going to be held accountable
for failing to pray.
Do we think that the disbeliever will
not be held accountable for failing to
pray? The disbeliever is held
accountable as well. Just because they
disbelieved
does not mean that they were not
expected to obey Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. If they had the ability to learn
about Islam, to seek out the truth, they
failed to do so or they rejected the
truth, then this person will be held
accountable for failing to fulfill that
truth. As Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
tells us that the people of the hellfire
will be asked
that they will be asked what has placed
you in this damnation in this in this in
this you know in this hell. And they
will say we were not of those who made
and we did not feed the poor.
Muslims are held accountable for that.
Non-Muslims as well. However,
they are held accountable in a different
way. A Muslim may be held accountable
specifically.
A person who rejected Islam will be held
accountable
generally and specifically for failing
to fulfill these obligations. Just
because a person rejects the truth
doesn't make it any less true and
doesn't make it any less obligatory upon
them. When Allah says in the Quran,
this applies to everyone whether they
accept it or not.
[Silence]
This is my f